[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to just the facts with jay jonah
jameson
the show that's dropped so many truth
bombs on that menace spider-man
that his brand is now toxic so
he's trying to trick you into thinking
he's a completely
different spider-man although my
competition disagreed that is a new
spider-man just look at him
oh this is danica hart host of the
danacast
doing a special joint broadcast because
you know i'm not sure why i agreed to do
this anymore but i don't need my glasses
to see that this spider-man has
totally new powers you mean those
dangerous bursts of energy
and electric punches of doom
and that camouflage man i wish i could
straight up vanish sometimes
like right now he just blends in
anywhere like a chameleon
or someone with something to hide like a
web of lies
plus he's designed all those cool new
gadgets
that gravity doohicky
that's very satisfying you ask me
it's all gadgets that's his scam
but if it web swings like a spider and
runs up walls like a spider
it's a menace he even does that
differently
haven't you noticed his totally unique
parkour style
you do know what parkour is right of
course leaping from one piece of private
property to another with no regard for
the law
but so what if he's swinging and jumping
even more obnoxiously
than before so i think this is a younger
spidey
just look at the bold choices in his
latest suit
spider-man's always changed his look
like some dilettante
who can't figure out what he wants well
i think wardrobe changes keep things
fresh
that outfit the media calls the
tracksuit really pops
and then there's this one with yellow
gauntlets i call the strike suit
because it's just so striking strikingly
terrifying
one spider's creepy enough but no he's
gonna put
four huge ones on that eyesore
okay jonah this kind of feels like i'm
trying to stop you yelling at clouds but
what'll it take to convince you it is an
all-new spider-man seeing both
spider-man
right in front of my face
very fast hold on they've come for me
avenge me new york
avenge me uh mr jameson
are you okay i'm fine
this just in there are two spider-men
and they still couldn't silence me so
there is a brand new spider-man i
couldn't hear you technical difficulties
jameson now
playstation